niveles récord en los indicadores de la
crisis climática la organización
meteorológica mundial alertó en su
informe 2021 que los océanos alcanzaron
máximos de calentamiento y acidificación
el derretimiento de los polos contribuyó
al aumento del nivel del mar y los
niveles de dióxido de carbono y metano
en la atmósfera superaron los del año
anterior el informe de hoy sobre el
estado del clima es una sombría letanía
del fracaso de la humanidad a la hora de
flotar los trastornos climáticos el
reporte también acusa que los últimos
siete años han sido los más calurosos de
los que se tiene constancia con
consecuencias que afectarán al mundo a
corto y largo plazo y olas de calor como
la que se está viendo en parte del
continente asiático que tendrán efectos
directos sobre la salud de la población
nardy hemos batido récords de
temperatura a nivel regional por ejemplo
el verano pasado batimos el máximo
europeo de 48.8 grados en el sur de
italia y también en canadá se batió el
máximo histórico con 49,6 grados
six degrees los datos siguen la última
evaluación climática de naciones unidas-
publicada este año y que advierte que la
humanidad debe reducir drásticamente sus
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
ya que cada vez estamos más cerca del
umbral de calentamiento global de 1.5
grados celsius punto en el que será
mucho más difícil evitar una catástrofe
climática